what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we're going to continue
watching The Witcher season 3 episode 3.
today uh John how are you I am excited
sir how are you doing great ladies and
gentlemen toss a coin to that like
button subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when a
reaction for the next episode is up here
on the Chanel as always thank you to
everyone who's joined our patreon page
full-length reaction watching along as
we sync with your own copy of The
Witcher available for our super sexy
rejects over there and we cover several
things exclusively with the reaction
highlights and watch alongs included we
gotta swim no action people let's go
are you even listening what does radovid
even mean I see people you know what I
see I mean there's only maybe like twice
feelings conflicted he's hiding
something and if I'm gonna help geralt
and need to find out what that is
because geralt is
a hammer that's what they called Walker
and Mission Impossible Fallout he's
intelligent he tries to hide it but he's
insightful oh you are swooning
is a knife I need to keep him away from
girl
you like him yeah you do I've cursed you
for chasing tale of every kind men women
dwarves elves polymorphic
regret nothing it was amazing but never
have I ever seen you have a crush
goddamn right
that's all right sorry this is a friend
foreign
flashbacks
[Music]
looks like a door knocker
hello Annika
she's missed you too
come on good thing she was so close by
asha's table salt that's not um it's not
very druidic I'm not a druid yeah right
I'm a werewolf whoa oh awesome amazing
girls high by the villagers to kill me
if you found me a cure instead
kept close to my chest it keeps me safe
wait this character seems familiar
whoever this major is they have quite a
variety of interests an extraction
Elixir
well done nothing
[Music]
sip that lean
I thought we were going to aratuta
Fantastic Beasts my most Secure Vault is
yours thank you I have one more favor my
ward needs a chaperone say no more Fabio
is at your disposal perfect age
finally nice
now let me see that Talis menu
constantly fiddling with
what's that for locate his plan keep an
eye on you but don't get into any
trouble
for sure
[Music]
whoa there seems to be some confusion
among your advisors
[Music]
did you see that how does this game work
it's like pinball meets dodgeball or
ping pong in the inevitable event of
their push North Nils guard has agreed
to leave rodania untouched they're
offering half of tameria as a vassal
State oh Lord wants to return on this
generous MILF Guardian investment
nothing we can't afford 200 and should
we find her first we turn the princess
of syndra over to them you are being
gone
as your most senior advisor I cannot
stress enough to stress too much the
only reason you have any power here is
sigismund is because of me don't forget
that
no one gets a private audience written
outside my perfume I might have been
told us they did he was right and
they're doing it again Vietnamese not
scheming alone Queen Hedwig has been
such a useful mood of late perhaps it's
time to make it useful to us you can see
him right hey I would hope but I don't
think so perhaps it's time to reach out
to one of your old Community
to say it might be useful oh great men
bleed and kill for this stuff only to
let it rust
that's because it's worthless it's too
soft to make anything useful
you can't eat it
if you made and you still like to try an
illusion designed to control the masses
the leader of the Brotherhood should
know all about that that's what supplies
make in this show I think Hugh land
Sorella was alive and shared the news
hope and Curry favor with the northern
Kings
I don't know what's more insulting that
you think my goals so basic whether you
free an elf Guardian prisoner of war the
lecture me on Northern Unity okay no
basic
but someone far more powerful is backing
him we can't let him get to her you want
me to help hide a princess whose
existence Means War exactly she deserves
to know what hers is capable of
she deserves control of her Destiny
teach her the ways of the force please
help me make this right after all this
time all your search and you actually
did it did what okay my mother
ah nicely done she didn't even realize
it
[Music]
Legend has it they take fairly novices
to their caves below the tower and turn
them into eels
there's no Legends
[Applause]
there's no book of monotones
my order of the emperor himself you owe
me 20 marks he stood oh his third has
got a return to eritus huh it's turd
that's not very nice
is turds Landing now bad news we're
getting slaughtered
forgive me I'm a fighter not a
politician I don't really know how to
sugarcoat the truth and that's exactly
what he's gonna want no Francesca has
made many sacrifices for her people what
makes you think her choices can't be
trusted because her choices are in
defiance of yours sir she's not fighting
to soften the north she's searching for
a girl
oh boy I'd like you to stay a while if
you would we can resolve this issue I
have no doubt make sure this man is fed
my Lord
it's the right side of the face cut gang
I asked for a private audience to
protect your secret
but cirilla
this really is out there
I'm having dreams about her
oh my Lord I have been in the field
Gallatin is a good fighter he knows the
land and the elves are loyal to him he
can deliver us the North Division among
the elves would only hurt our calls on
both fronts
yep
but yeah yeah I mean he's only as good
as its leader I know a good leader when
I see one it gave me no pleasure to
punish you oh
but I had to know you could be trusted
that I had not lost you are you ready to
come home okay here yes Dad yes
prove it with tongue
you're trying to see has consequences
too girl there are already consequences
yes yeah and not just for Siri I thought
that by taking her off the board the
world would stop trying to use it nope
she's certainly not an aratusian witch
sourcing magic out of stones or hemp
which she can be she's the bridge you're
right
[Music]
well that's deeply worrying what
[Laughter]
something happened that affected your
mind do you remember what happened I was
in my Uber
a magic man the woman with a funny voice
they will help the man you knew him
that's cool
at school
oh no she's reverted
what was his name Taryn
oh
I'm so close
stupid Witcher oh hi
um
all right for her
come on no
no more time
oh we were so close don't worry
give it 20 more minutes
[Music]
he's based on the touristy unpredictable
that's what's enough of them to know oh
yeah
oh my God it is fantastic
The Specialist girl they are
unpredictable oh nagini yeah
okay there's a dragon
oh my God basilisk it can only be killed
by seeing its reflection in the mirror
very Medusa you're all running this is a
wyvern and it's young and it's
because you're keeping it in this cave
if you don't like my little show why
don't you just piss off
oh yeah oh that's not good
oh
oh yeah
somebody get a mirror
whoa oh my God it's becoming Jurassic
Park
[Music]
wait a stay Incognito here Siri
poor creature
no
yeah
it's fun getting into trouble I've got
to go thank you where are you going and
good luck picking us spin off
your hands off me
ugh I'll take it from here what are you
doing here bringing my ward to get a
proper education when she obviously
needs forgive her Rita Rita look at me
don't you dare take your eyes off me
it's not away from the eyes not around
the eyes into my eyes has an apology for
her impudence allow me to treat you
ladies for some luxury should we take
The Waters at silverhairen yeah
oh
yes
this is what the shows were made for
magic let's stay here it's Heaven we've
got we're gone to heaven tell me
a true that the mutations make them
impotent not this rich in a witch
atrocious isn't it tell me all about it
[Music]
oh the wine no get it yourself oh
yeah fight
what the hell is wrong with you before
you spoil everything I can't spoil
something that's already rotten this is
tense I don't want to do this tomorrow
I'll be expected to go Crawling Back to
the Brotherhood tail between my legs
begging for forgiveness because auratuza
is my best hope of protecting you from
those who hunt you our best chance to be
play the ACT
is one of the most powerful sorceresses
on this continent you should be grateful
that she's willing to teach you
I'm just trying to keep you safe man you
told me to never apologize for my power
and yet that's all you seem to do you
want to be a great leader you want to
change the world well guess what the day
to day of leading is dealing with a lot
of vapid power hungry they're
both right
it's a version of myself I have to be
here so you need to find the version of
yourself
I know you're not
you're not oh you have no idea sister
Jennifer's gonna end up just burning our
twosa down every time she gets welcome
back it gets worse
very badly
oh telling him the truth just wanted her
to know what she did
forces parents to make the hardest
choices of their lives and possible ones
even chances are they toil over it for
the rest of their lives does that make
you feel better or worse girls could she
have toiled in front of me that she
actually loved you I wouldn't have done
anything to make her smile she was sick
she needed water so I went to get her
some and when I came back she was
oh chill after the best she could the
way she knew how
this can't have been the only choice who
wasn't
simply the one she made
huh what she thought best
I won't abandon Siri even if it cost me
my life can she stay here while I work
out how to help her where are you going
I would use her reunion war is coming
and she's at the center of it Majors
have kept Kings in check for centuries
we'll find a way to toxicity is
infectious toxicity of our city we host
a conclave of Mages we haven't had one
since before sodden and then we went to
war so we do differently this time
instead of Discord and debate
we focus on trust which can lead to
Discord and debate we do a team building
exercise if we have any hope of
appealing to the Kings we first have to
find better versions of ourselves I'm
willing to try
you
student becomes the master
[Applause]
come on buddy and this was left with my
man servant from a secret admirer
courtesy of me of God see I told you
deeper they're not so bad
wow
I want men on every door and window
nobody gets interrupting me tell the
gatekeeper to scout the perimeter and
bring me bread of its Manchester
immediately
yes where is the manservant take the
king to his Chambers My Lord
[Music]
laughs
well
there's that for that talk of making the
queen more useful you and Philip did
this
you won't get away with it you're
letting him in on it go back to sucking
on the Royal teeth until you're just
drunk enough to forget this terrible
tragedy and keep your mouth shut
I already let him in on it I'm I'm not
sure it doesn't seem like there's enough
of a wedge between the brothers that he
wouldn't believe him or entertain the
idea now his brother trusts him he
always seems so exasperated by dijkstra
so
[Music]
thank you
right on Pleasure
amen
that'll do pig
I wish you were there today
you Hedwig had a sick neck but God that
was a workout to cut through geez no I
wonder what the extra thought of my
piece to resistance
no never expects a head in a box do they
nobody expects the Spanish how did she
manage to portal into the palace and
through my protection enchantments maybe
because the portal was special a portal
is a portal I've seen your portals this
wasn't that are we talking about actual
portals swirling black Vortex of
unnervingness for mage but
that works for nilfgaard
excellent
working with
God
the White Flame is just a means to an
end a small piece
at least I still have a face
yeah what's the deal
oh I'm growing tired of being kept in
the dark if he wants me to go along with
his little plan I have a demand of my
own
what you know like a cool hat money plot
of land what news from the scouts
with the rounded generous it's a Roundy
General I've known you to March into bat
with little more than a breastplate made
of chicken bones and a stick for a sword
a few Surfer he was an idiot that's what
the White Flame said to me when he came
to free me those exact words
you're strong for a scrawny
oh wow
[Music]
to symbolize his shattered state of
being why do you do that wait you mean
kill his buddy yeah I think it's I think
it's some for the White Flame well why
would the White Flame want to try to
outrank him try to go above rank well
and like cause distressed among the
elves and stuff
the wild Hunt
[Music]
join us
holy yes
hey
that's
put it on
table for you
yeah that's why geralt had to shoot
clear them out yeah yeah
that's why that was as difficult as it
was
a massive reveal there but okay
to show that they're actually coming
they're coming this time yeah yeah it
kind of tease him again now that we're
you know
almost to the end of the first half of
this yes
what'd you think that was pretty good
it's pretty decent I think I liked the
episode the second episode still the
most out of all of them
but uh you know things are progressing
uh certainly I don't know I like topping
around I thought there were some really
good scenes between
uh Syrian Yen and and to Saya and and
those things you know there was some
some good like juicy back and forth like
uh you know debate both you as you said
both of them kind of got a point you
know where they're coming from in this
friction of how to handle you know
diplomacy versus power versus the whole
structure of the way things work yada
yada and you know her going around town
and and kind of getting into little
hijinks and stuff like that like in the
previous episodes It's
I don't know she's good at getting into
trouble it's part of her character
obviously but at the same time this one
felt maybe the most natural for that
side of things
um there are still times where I'm like
why why you gotta disrupt this show
to not not like I'm happy she freed the
creature but at the same time I'm like
yeah you can't you're just going out of
your way to call attention to yourself
but uh I thought it was the least amount
of that in this episode
uh hey yeah I mean I don't know there's
so many chess pieces moving around
that's kind of the first thing that came
to mind and then you know got at least a
little bit of time with geralt and
yasker we haven't I don't feel like
we've really had like a good like
buddy moment for them yet this season
but uh you know it's nice to get them
together
and then various other you know
machinations I don't know what what
struck you the most
what struck me the most what did you
think of the episode
I think that for the I thought it got
better as it went along I think in the
first like 15 20 minutes it wasn't quite
clicking for me but this is this might
be a bit of a silly statement but this
feels the most politically heavy-handed
that it's ever been I don't mean that in
a in a negative way actually like that's
when when those are firing on all
cylinders that's when it's the most
exciting you know uh when this show is
first debuting it's I think it's really
easy for Fantasy IP to compare with one
another and I don't know what inspires
what necessarily and but you know when
this show first came out it was
recited by a lot for like Netflix
wanting to have their own Game of
Thrones in a way and this episode
is not quite the answer to that nor is
it even House of the Dragon but it's the
most akin to it I would say considering
all the different royalties that you're
cutting around to and the
all the things of the dichotomy of every
single situation of what they're Landing
into with every single conversation and
choice and belief and mysticism versus
reality there was a lot happening here
that I thought was intriguing for the
most part it is there's so much plot
lines happening with the one Central
focus of everyone trying to get to Siri
so it's I like that I can at least
adjust my brain back to that at all
times yeah it is okay there's a lot
happening here you got this tearing girl
possessed by which there's a witch thing
happening here they want to keep Syria
alive then you got the with nilf
guard happening here then you got
what's it called not Riverdale River
no that's redania rodania rodania you
got rodania you have all that political
Warfare happening and then killing the
queen
uh there's just so much there's so much
going on and I'm waiting to see how it
all coalesces into this one solid
conclusion sure because it is a lot of
moving chess pieces to keep up with and
some are not as interesting as others
um when the queen died I was like okay
now this is really interesting finally
because I like the brother a lot the
prince but everything else was like this
is always kind of like wavering for me
and something that is truly intriguing
or not
um but I love how you know their
Jennifer is in this position where she's
trying to create community and trust but
then you have you know people like Rants
and other Mages who are really bad and
some in secrecy who we don't know about
so we're trying to also coordinate a way
where trust can be built but it seems
like there's a lot that can completely
undo that trust at any given moment now
um yeah there's a lot of things there's
also this thing about like uh respecting
hierarchy or finding your own
individualism and it's like to want to
just follow the typical Royal path or
can they change the way uh the future
unfolds instead of just being adherent
to history and that's where you got
these oddballs like Siri and geralt to
seem like a perfect match for each other
because they like to play by
um they have a moral code and a moral
compass but they want to play about
their own rules versus uh what everyone
else is trying to play the political
landscape the way how it's always done
and that's what puts Jennifer and Syria
at odds and I did really like that scene
between the two of them because
yeah when you're seeing um
what's the word post posturing this type
of Personality that Jennifer was doing
oh yeah yeah she's I guess yeah yeah
she's just posturing as somebody as as
sort of vapid and and engrossed in this
insulated power cycle as the rest of
them yeah uh but I'm liking The Sire
performance
um
she's like she's evolved and
she has that thing with Jennifer of like
you've always caused me so much trouble
and I've always believed in you but I
feel like you keep betraying me but I
feel like there's still potential so I
like that back and forth between them it
still sings loud and clear
uh but yeah I mean for the most part
pretty good stuff uh there's enough
there's enough intriguing twists and
turns for stuff to happen but it is it
is very convoluted at the moment to the
point where
uh
I don't know someone commented on one of
our patreon posts about how they've read
the book so they know where it's going
they feel like they're beating us over
the head with it but because we haven't
read the book that we don't know where
it's going and I'm like yeah I don't
really know where it's I know it's like
there's a certain point we gotta land to
with this wild Hunt Siri and all that
but at the same time and like the
choices that Siri's gonna make
but there's also all these other details
of different moving pieces you know when
yaskir and the prince like yeah there's
a lot to there's a lot going on right
now yeah that did start to weigh on this
episode for me a little bit of like whoa
wait hold on pause let me reorient yeah
which kingdom and which you know Twisted
you know sordid lies or deceits are are
being yeah
paid off or touched upon here yeah it
can be a little overwhelming especially
in an episode yeah that is going for
more of like the politics of each given
situation
yeah they do a lot of explaining to the
politics instead of really showing a lot
of the consequences of the politics and
so I want to kind of just live with a
good amount it's turning into like too
much of play to me at times like too
much like a stage play and I want to see
a little bit more going down
otherwise I'm just cute of a lot of
encyclopedic information and it becomes
a little bit hard yeah um which is why I
think like the the geralt story lines
are always interesting because you're
getting a combination of it all of of
not just like action scenes but
I mean if there's one way to put it I
don't mean just like crazy choreography
or something but yeah like there's
action happening and there's information
being disposed as well and I like to
assume where he is uh talking about his
mom and confiding in Annika
uh about a memory I think we did see
that memory yeah we saw that memory
right like we actually saw that memory
yeah it was kind of flashing back I'm
sorry I was almost a little surprised
they didn't like put an image or we
wanted to keep the camera on Henry
Cavill watch him much inform them tears
watch him cry watch him cry so we can
act he's not just a hammer and so seeing
geralt be so much more vulnerable this
season too is something I'm just like I
I did not know they were going to
pendulum swing him into so much
vulnerability here he is such a softy
I mean yeah he's a killer he's the same
Witcher killer kind of guy he is but he
is such a softy this time yeah and I
mean it's fun to watch I mean Henry
Cavill is really good at playing every
layer of geralt and making them
I could send Like You could argue I I
think that yeah like they have really
hit that pedal pretty hard this season
in terms of his shift as a character his
more fatherly inclinations uh but at the
same time I I think he plays them really
well and it is
fun to have that difference of dynamic
and uh
yeah I mean that's that's often the
heart of things like I'm still invested
in this like core little family unit
though they may be so spread apart and
anguished at the moment
uh yeah but I feel like everyone's just
trying to make the best choice possible
yeah everyone's just doing the best they
can based on their chosen ideology yeah
and and calling upon all the resources
and and sort of like close favors they
can to see this through or find the best
you know outcome for Siri ultimately
happens man
truly truly it does
uh but yeah so far I mean this is like a
seven out of six to seven out of ten
somewhere there I'd be like a 69 sure
I'll meet you right around there Teeter
and right there it seems like this this
season especially has kind of been like
flipping back and forth between feeling
more like kind of more modern
sensibilities and and you know more
not Blockbuster but there's just
something at odds I feel like in terms
of the levels of when they go literary
political versus when they just lean
into like talking straighter at us and
having more fun with it and I'm just I'm
hoping the next couple episodes can
maybe like find the Middle with those
two things
because it's like the the first episode
felt more like ah we're moving and it
kind of feels like you know some kind of
movie some kind of Hollywood movie and
then the second episode was more like
okay yeah yeah we're Tamp we're even
though the the dialogue's still there
oftentimes these flourishes that feel
like they're using very modern phrasing
or modern
colloquialisms alongside the period
stuff and then this episode I thought
they kind of leaned they still have that
but they leaned back toward the more
convoluted high-minded political and so
I just I keep hoping they can find where
the levels harmonize because I feel like
they have been sort of all over the
place this season
and uh and white white flame man oh yeah
we're gonna actual scene with him like
being a leader guy
that was really messed up it was I hear
it even brought him there yeah
he's his buddy and and then they on a
true Bond yeah
but that's the thing man you gotta ruin
your loyalty he convinced him to come
here he's an awful guy
flame Orca here okay here I mean yeah
this is such an office his faith just
brings so much pain and Incarnation yes
I really like watching him but but also
yeah his his decisions I'm like oh
uh part of me is like I want you to have
some kind of redemption Arc but at the
same time I'm like ah it wasn't like
Robbie and Mel was begging to come here
no you know yeah you thought you were
just going to give him a boost and and
yeah
um show him what you were so invested in
and then we got the monolith being
brought back
oh yeah there's so much there's a lot
happening yes and there was a creature
in this episode too
what when you know in the Box in the
show she said oh yeah yeah
I feel like you just kept mentioning
Fantastic Beasts and I do feel like
there's a thing of like the first season
I was like oh yeah there's gonna be a
lot of beasts throughout this and now
I'm like oh yeah I never want monster
shows up I'm like oh yeah there's
monsters in this shoot it's kind of easy
to forget now
it feels a little bit like they're
forcing a monster and yeah like we need
it
it's still technically what the premise
was well most people seem to be liking
this season more than last that's good
[Music]
I think it's a fine season I think it's
fine I'm happy to be here I'm happy to
be watching it I'm enjoying this it's a
treat but at the same time I yeah this
has not been as just smooth and truly
engrossing like I find myself on the
edge of being like come on come on you
you've got all the ingredients you can
get there you know I'm starting to feel
like just another fantasy show
a little bit it yeah dips at times into
those moments like when they have like a
real you know good monologue or
something like they're they're elements
that still dip into what
not to keep harping on that first season
but I think part of what made that such
a splash was that it did kind of border
on being yeah not just another fantasy
show but another thing that has like
this unique but like caliber to A Game
of Thrones where it is yeah
I don't know it's pitched in a certain
way that it seems to have not been able
to consistently maintain yeah thus far
and and so yeah it's it just feels like
things are moving a lot faster and
they're adapting it's again it's that
weird thing of like I know I haven't
read the source material so I'm not like
holding it up to that but I can just
feel
that whatever this is based on is
probably probably does not look like
this
Maybe
um this one's apparently closer to the
books in the second season sure but
possibly uh
just yeah I don't know I don't know it's
hard to put your finger on it and I'm
not sure we'll know until like we're
done with at least this first half yeah
because yeah it's I I am like yeah I'm
having a good time but it is a little
back and forth in terms of like you know
the greatness and the investment you
know getting sucked in
and riveted rivid
yeah I think that maybe the intention is
that you know we're building to the wild
Hunt and this is when things is supposed
to be going crazy so that's why the
pacing is the way it is but I don't know
there's something about the way the
pacing and tone overall is like it's so
intermittent for me when I'm engrossed
to not being engrossed it's just waves
in and out too many too much well
because sometimes it's being an action
thing or or more I don't know again
there
there are times when it I think you need
to flesh the world in a slightly
different way and spend a little more
time with certain characters so that
like all the convolution doesn't
overwhelm you the same way and that you
can form stronger attachments to various
characters it's weird again there are
times where they'll dip into having that
level of coordination and like
you know the kind of like oversight of
the entire board that they're you know I
feel like you can watch a thing and as a
viewer or reader not have the full
context in your mind but you can tell
that whoever's writing and guiding your
experience like has the complete map in
View and is guiding your eye and I don't
get as strong of like that sense of like
solid control solid like
I don't know consistency of vision or
something
I'm not sure what it is like it's good
that we have all like our main
characters being served pretty well in
terms of screen time and all that
answers are here and everybody's yeah
showing up and doing a great job and
certainly some characters like dextro is
certainly like more interesting this
season
um but there are ways in which I feel
like they could really make these places
and certain key but still supporting
players feel more Vivid and alive so
like the impacts really register when a
big development comes or when a subtle
you know deceit or whatever comes down
the line yeah
it's a
yeah again it's like it's all the
elements are here all the ingredients
are present but yeah I just don't feel
like it's as comprehensive whatever
blend they're putting together it's not
quite it's it's like
it feels
it's like there's Gucci and then you can
buy the ones that are like this looks
like a Gucci bag and sometimes it feels
like it when I forget yeah but then when
I was looking at actually manufactured
by your teeth yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
this is a pretty solid movement
you can tell what it's based on you can
tell what it's attempting to do but like
yeah I don't know yeah you gotta at some
sometimes you gotta drop the coin to get
the actual authentic thing yeah you got
to put in the investment
so we'll see it's yeah it's like it
doesn't carry itself quite like the
thing it's trying to be or trying
according to Netflix is number one on
Netflix again of course absolutely has
to be always says it right I'm like I'm
sure yeah man I'm sure that terrible
audience score I mean the audience score
I just saw it um
I didn't read any FDA because of this
show in particular
especially because I like season two I'm
like and that heads so like I've had
time to this audience score it might
spoil something and or it might be like
it's just much people mad about Henry
Cavill is the people who actually don't
like the show or is it people who don't
like us treating The Source material and
I'm like it's a completely different
argument for me to be having I mean to
me I don't want to make myself put it in
my purview so that way I I'm not
thinking about it yeah when watching it
yeah
um but it is fascinating to be like yeah
the critics I mean the audience score is
not good on this but it could be a
review bombing but I really don't know
like 49
see I feel like if they were going to
review bomb it would be when they switch
out guys recap
I feel like they what the people are
saying that Henry Cavill left because
the show was being done terribly oh I
see so by in in support of him though
they'll basically go and bomb it as yeah
yeah just being like this is crap
regardless because Henry said it's crap
but he did rumored to have thought that
it was crap uh yeah I'll never
understand before yeah I mean that's
something clearly you left it it's not
you know come on yeah no you're safe to
presume that he left it because of
things were not going well here yeah I
would have to imagine there's no real
reason for him to leave otherwise I feel
like the schedule and his passion for
the character could easily be worked out
if that was he loves Witcher like the
world and the books and stuff and you
know
I mean watching these three seasons I
mean like I I while still enjoying this
again and while still looking forward to
and hoping that it Nails you know the
mark
uh you know it's definitely changed over
time and I could see why he doesn't feel
like he's maybe on the same ship yeah
and here I am going yeah it's starting
to feel that way yeah for me as a viewer
but guys
um you still enjoying the season leave
your thoughts down below
uh we we know we tend to attract the
very optimistic crowd and the more
positive thinking about so I appreciate
that even when we're a little more on
the negative side I noticed that we
still attract that kind of audience and
I I like that I'd rather have that
rather have a bunch of Rage clicks yeah
it's nice it's actually nice to see
people being like I actually really like
this rather than watching something you
really like and having everyone else be
like this is terrible what's wrong with
you but let us know your thoughts down
below we'll see you guys soon thanks for
being here
[Music]